"Cowboy Bebop" is such a popular anime
that it's broken out of the anime bubble
and made its way into the zeitgeist. So popular
and foundational a text is the late '90s anime
that it's frequently recommended as a good
starting place for newcomers to the anime genre.
Basically, if you had to sum up
"Cowboy Bebop," it's the animated
version of the Joss Whedon sci-fi series
"Firefly" before "Firefly" became a thing.
Debuting in 1998, the anime show follows a
group of "space cowboys" skirting the law
and struggling to survive in a
spaceship whose name also happens
to be — you guessed it — Cowboy Bebop. The
protagonist of this tale is Spike Spiegel,
a cool-as-ice bounty hunter with a dark past who
rarely shuns the opportunity to make his work fun.
Joining Spike on these intergalactic
bounty hunts is his close friend,
Jet Black, as well as Faye Valentine, Ed, and an
adorable dog named Ein. There are action-packed
fight sequences and romantic subplots galore, so
it's got a little something for everybody. It's
easy to see why the show was so popular,
even if it only lasted for one season.
The original anime was so popular that it
eventually got its own live-action reboot on
Netflix. The project was originally announced at
Variety in 2017. Then, in 2019, that same outlet
reported the project had cast John Cho, Mustafa
Shakir, and Daniella Pineda to play Spike, Jet,
and Faye, respectively. "Cowboy Bebop" finally
debuted in November after releasing more than
one exciting trailer to get audiences excited. But
it wasn't enough because, this week, Netflix just
made a major decision about Season 2 that diehard
fans of the show are going to be sad to hear.
In early December, The Hollywood Reporter reported
the exclusive news that, after just one season,
Netflix has chosen to cancel the live-action
"Cowboy Bebop" adaptation. The streaming platform
was swift in its decision, opting to cut the
project loose following its November 19th release.
According to the outlet, the cancellation of
"Cowboy Bebop" is likely due, to some degree,
to the low ratings on Rotten Tomatoes. The series
currently holds a 46% critics score and a 56%
average audience score. Among the negative
reviews of the show, Time magazine remarked,
"It misses the core appeal of 'Cowboy Bebop,'
which finds its deepest resonance
in a richly textured surface."
The New York Times was particularly
tough on the show, noting,
"In its resolute ordinariness,
the main value of this new 'Bebop'
would be to drive you back to watch the old one."
Decider's review echoes these
sentiments, stating at one point,
"'Cowboy Bebop' isn't cringingly bad, but
it's also not particularly memorable either."
Per The Hollywood Reporter's reporting, it
was also noted that, on Netflix's Top 10 site,
"Cowboy Bebop" accrued more than 74 million
viewing hours globally in the days following
its mid-November premiere. However, this
didn't last long, as there was a reported 59%
drop in viewing hours between late November
and early December — a disappointing turn,
to be sure. It was, however, noted
that the streaming giant, quote,
"takes pride" in gambling as it did with a
live-action adaptation of "Cowboy Bebop."
A final nail in the coffin here is
likely the production costs to bring
the anime world of "Cowboy Bebop"
to life in a live-action setting.
Although there is no official reporting
on how much it cost to make the show,
it's evident that efforts were made to make every
facet of the show closely resemble the '90s anime.
So far, social media reactions to the cancellation
have largely been mixed. On Twitter, one user
wasn't exactly dismayed to hear the news,
claiming that the show lacked,
quote, "the spirit of the original."
Another Twitter user thought that the series
wasn't all bad but that it ultimately failed
"to justify itself." And one person implored
Netflix to reconsider the decision, writing,
"I was looking forward to
seeing where it went. Bummed."
There are plenty of sad fans out there,
including some who think the move was in
part because of a vocal minority of, quote, "the
social media hate brigade" complaining about it.
One commenter on Twitter weighed in, saying
that while they liked the actors and the plot,
the title was not working for
them. They went on to suggest,
"Maybe if it had a different name, more
people would've given it a shot...???"
Additionally, the cast of "Cowboy Bebop"
shared their reactions to the sad news.
John Cho put up a very colorful post
on Twitter, using a GIF of Tom Selleck
saying "I'm okay" while appearing to be
not quite okay to explain his feelings.
Mustafa Shakir also opted to post a comment on
Twitter without directly addressing the news.
The Jet Black actor posted a tweet that said, "See
you, space cowboys!" and added some emojis and a
GIF from the "Cowboy Bebop" anime as a farewell
to the show. On Instagram, Daniella Pineda shared
a photo of a celebratory toast going horribly
wrong, captioning the photo with a simple "Ugh."
At the end of the day, reboots and
remakes will never go out of style,
so there's always a chance "Cowboy Bebop" could
be redone or picked up by another network.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don’t miss a single one.